un concert de klaxon pour protester
contre des bourdonnements de turbine une
centaine d'habitants s'étaient donné
rendez-vous aux abords de l'aérodrome de
Toussus-le-Noble ce samedi 13 mai à
l'occasion de la Journée internationale
de sensibilisation au bruit les
riverains étaient venus dénoncer
l'absence de mesure concrètes sur les
nuisances sonores causées par les
aéronautes il y a des jours où ça
devient assez infernal parce que ça
n'arrête pas c'est par vague
et les avions des fils les uns derrière
les autres depuis 2011 des habitants
impactés des communes limitrophes se
sont rassemblés au sein du collectif
alliance associative l'an passé environ
119000 mouvements d'aéronefs ont été
enregistrés à l'aérodrome de
Toussus-le-Noble aujourd'hui
c'est notre light motif c'est réduction
du trafic et surtout réduction du trafic
des avions bruyants et mis en place
d'indicateurs qui vont permettre
effectivement de mesurer cette baisse de
nuisance c'était les pilotes volat
aérodrome depuis 3 ans selon lui des
efforts ont été faits pour minimiser la
pollution sonore il demande aux
habitants de la patience en attendant le
renouvellement progressif de la flotte
faire des avions plus silencieux je
pense que toute leur revendications il
faut les écouter il faut les entendre en
effet on est sur des anciennes machines
qui parfois font un petit peu de bruit
pour autant on a pas mal de contraintes
sur l'aérodrome notamment pour des
circuits à respecter pour ne pas gêner
ou minimiser de la chaîne envers les
riverains ça prend du temps de changer
un sport ça prend du temps de changer
des technologies et que c'est en marche
ça va dans le bon sens et même si ça va
pas la vitesse qu'il le souhaiterait ce
qui est peut-être entendable
bah ça avance et c'est quand même
positif le collectif envisage d'autres
mobilisations si au canal corps n'est
trouvé avec ces deux pistes le site de
tous le noble et le 4e aérodrome
d'aviation d'affaires et de loisirs en
France